ich grüße sie herzlich manchmal fragt
man sich schon für wen sie eigentlich
noch läuten die kirchenglocken am
sonntagmorgen der tatsache ist dass es
immer weniger menschen in die
gotteshäuser zieht und nicht nur in die
mit den glocken
wir sprechen gleich darüber woran das
liegen mag
ein fünftel der schweizer bevölkerung
macht einen bogen nicht nur um kirchen
auch um moscheen oder synagogen hat
religion noch zukunft ein gespräch mit
dem religionssoziologen hans joas
hermann burger der mann aus worten
sprach artist zauberkünstler vor 25
jahren hat er sich das leben genommen
was ist vom autor von shilton geblieben
das gespräch mega metropolen enge
wohnräume und verdichtetes bauen
architektur hat eine alternative
lebensraum nicht als festgefügt das
muster sondern als vertikales dorf ein
film
[Musik]
wer heutzutage religiöse bedürfnisse hat
hat die qual der wahl
christentum buddhismus islam oder
esoterik in unserer multi options-
gesellschaft kann mittlerweile
tatsächlich jeder nach seiner fasson
glücklich werden
manch einer probiert sich sogar durch
verschiedene glaubensrichtungen durch
oder lässt es eben ganz bleiben nimmt
durch diese gesellschaftliche tendenz
der auflösung die religiöse
oberflächlichkeit zu und wenn ja wo
führt das hin zu moral verlust und
siebter fall braucht der mensch zu
mensch sein am ende gar die religion
julia decker hat hans joas an unter
führenden religionssoziologen unser tage
zu diesen fragen eingeladen
warum haben sie als soziologe die
religion als eines ihrer spezialgebiete
gewählt also ursprünglich sicher nicht
deshalb weil das ein besonders modisch
oder karrieremäßig viel versprechen der
gegenstand war es ist genau umgekehrt
jahrzehntelang galt bei vielen speziell
bei vielen sozialwissenschaftlern
religion also etwas was an bedeutung
laufen verliert und früher oder später
vielleicht ganz verschwindet das hat
sich jetzt in den letzten 10 20 jahren
außerordentlich verändert so dass man
sehr viele nachfragen bekommt das hat
sicher auch den anteil von arbeiten über
religion unter meinen schriften
verstärkt aber dahinter ist ursprünglich
ein viel stärker persönliches motiv
ein motiv das damit zu tun hat dass ich
zunächst einmal als kind und jugendliche
außerordentlich intensiv gläubig war der
karriere
ja das ist kompliziert nicht wirklich
von meinem elternhaus aus also ich bin
zwar in einem total katholischen milieu
aufgewachsen
aber meine eltern hatten sich vor allem
ein vater im zusammenhang mit dem
nationalsozialismus von glauben doch
sehr weit entfernt ich verwende deshalb
manchmal den ausdruck brust totalitäres
christentum um zu sagen das ist nach
1945 in deutschland zwar christian
gegeben hat die sich einfach in einer
art ununterbrochenen kontinuität gesehen
haben aber schon auch viele gegeben hat
ganz wichtig war zu verarbeiten was da
eigentlich passiert ist im dritten reich
und warum die kirchen also das musste
man jetzt sehr viel differenzierter
sagen aber nicht wirklich eine starke
quelle des widerstands gegen den
nationalsozialismus und seine verbrechen
waren also ich würde was mich betrifft
genau diese konstellation als
biografische ausschlaggebend bezeichnen
die spannung zwischen der verarbeitung
des nationalsozialismus und dem was am
glauben attraktiv ist
das heißt aber eben auch dass man nicht
einfach einen milieu katholizismus
fortschreiben kann sondern gassmann neue
glaubensformen aber auch neue formen
intellektuelle rechtfertigung für den
glauben sozusagen finden muss so habe
ich das natürlich jetzt als kind hätte
ich das nicht so formuliert ja aber im
eigenen rückblick auf kindheit und
jugend sehe ich das als für mich
bestimmen
sie scheuen sich auch nicht als im
interviews oder artikeln auch sich als
praktizierender katholik zu outen wenn
ich das mal so sagen darf
das ist ja fern wissenschaftler in
europa doch eher ungewöhnlich das ist so
wohl spielt wirklich eine ganz große
rolle für meine ganze entwicklung auf
allen gebieten dass ich so sehr viel
zeit in den usa verbracht habe ja und
weiterhin jedes jahr monatelang
verbringe und da ist die situation
tatsächlich anders
obwohl auch in den usa es unter den
geistes- und sozialwissenschaftlern
viele leute gibt die keine religiöse
bindung haben ist es sehr normal auch
eine zu haben ja nichts wie hier das
leute meinen beispielsweise über
religion sollte nur solche leute
wissenschaftliche arbeiten die selber
persönlich mit dem glauben nichts zu tun
haben das wird mir entgegengebracht hat
das rennen dann die wissenschaftlichkeit
mir persönlich spricht man sage ich
jetzt voller selbstbewusstsein irgendwie
wissenschaftlichkeit eigentlich nicht ab
aber es gibt schon leute die sagen ist
das nicht schwierig bräuchte man nicht
ist hans oder so und dann antworte ich
darauf zb warum sagen sie nicht den
leuten die über die frauenbewegung
arbeiten
sie dürften keinerlei sympathien mit dem
feminismus haben
nur dann könnten sie ein reales
realistisches bild von der
frauenbewegung entwickeln also
komischerweise wird das auf die meisten
sozialen bewegungen nicht angewandt nur
leute die völlig desinteressiert an
ökologischen fragen sind sollten
wissenschaftliche über die
umweltbewegung arbeiten also da ist
irgendwas unlogisches drinnen
ich sage natürlich darf die
wissenschaftliche beschäftigung mit
religion nicht einfach glaubens
voraussetzungen sozusagen zum zur
grundlage des eigenen vorteils machen
insofern trage zwei verschiedene hüte
wissenschaftler hut sozusagen und einen
als gläubiger aber die wissenschaftliche
beschäftigung mit religion darf auch
nicht auf unkontrollierten
säkularistischen voraussetzungen büro
also eine situation in der man sagt nur
leute säkularistische art dürfen
wissenschaftliche über religionen
arbeiten halte ich für für sie wenn man
sagen würde nur atheisten dürfen sich
wissenschaftlich mit religion
geschrieben sie haben ein buch
geschrieben das sehr viel diskutiert
wurde
das heißt der glaube als option etwas
buch nimmt zwei thesen auf die oft eher
rezipiert werden wenn man von religion
spricht die eine these die
modernisierung für zur säkularisierung
und die zweite these sagt
säkularisierung für zum moral verlust
ich würde gerne diese beiden thesen mit
ihnen anschauen weil sie da die zitiert
widersprechen
die erste these modernisierung führt zur
säkularisierung also zu verweltlichung
zur religion verlust aber wenn ich es
richtig verstehe lautet die these so jäh
fortschrittlicher die bilder der
wissenschaftlichen gesellschaft ist
desto weniger ist sehr religiös
beziehungsweise ihre mitglieder
sie sagen das stimmt nicht warum stimmt
das nicht
es ist ja sensationell ist an der these
erst mal wenn man sich damit auf klingt
ab kontrollieren
ja es klingt man muss fragen wo in
welchem land klingt es plausibel ist
klingt vor allem in einer ganzen reihe
europäischer länder plausibel nun
bestreite ich ja nicht die tatsache der
säkularisierung also das ist ein
missverständnis dass es immer wieder
gibt es ist bekannt ich kritisiere die
säkularisierung stacy und dann
widersprechen mehr leute und sagen sie
können aber doch nicht leugnen dass
ostdeutschland oder tschechien oder
schweden um typische beispiele zu nehmen
außerordentlich säkularisierten
gesellschaften heute sind sagt das
bestreite ich auch in keinem augenblick
das ist so ja und ich will das ganze
ernst nehmen
die frage ist aber wie erklärt man das
und die säkularisierung these tut eben
so als läge die erklärung in der
modernisierung mit muss man fragen was
genau heißt dann modernisierung ich
glaube die einfachste form um das zu
umschreiben ist wirtschaftliches
wachstum und wissenschaftliche und
technologische fortschritt so in den
europäischen ländern in denen
säkularisierung weit fortgeschritten ist
die these eine bestimmte plausibilität
sie hat sie zum beispiel nie gehabt für
die vereinigten staaten von amerika da
niemand bestreitet dass unter dem
gesichtspunkt wirtschaftlichen wachstums
oder wissenschaftlich technischen
fortschritts die usa eine höchst moderne
gesellschaft sind aber die usa sind
gleichzeitig eine tief religiöse
religiös außerordentlich digitale
gesellschaft also passt ist in den usa
aber nein die usa also über die usa kann
man mit sicherheit nicht über einen
leisten schlagen aber man kann doch
zahlen nehmen die zb die ganz
unterschiedlichen formen von
religiosität in den usa alle zur
kenntnis nehmen
da gibt es in europa die neigung immer
nur an einen bornierten protestantischen
fundamentalismus zu denken wenn von
religion in den usa die rede ist aber
das ist eben nur eine verhaftung der
religiosität in den usa und es gibt sehr
viele andere und die führen insgesamt
dazu dass ein enorm hoher also weit über
allen europäischen werten liegen der
anteil der amerikanischen bevölkerung im
umfragen glaubensüberzeugungen äußert
glauben sie an gott glauben sie dass
nach dem physischen tod noch etwas kommt
oder eben auch tatsächlich meinetwegen
am sonntag in den gottesdienst geht und
so weiter also da hat an
diesen praktiken und da gibt es nichts
das phänomen zb zusammenhang religion
und geld dass reichere
bevölkerungsschichten jetzt auch in den
usa weniger religiös sind oder direkt
das gemeine im moment also tatsächlich
wie sie gesagt haben muss man sobald man
über die usa redet eben die
verschiedensten regionen der usa die
verschiedensten einwanderer edwin usw
kassen würden sie sagen voneinander
unterscheiden
es gibt schon einigermaßen
säkularisierte akademischen milieus aber
auch die bei weitem nicht in dem ausmaß
wie in den meisten europäischen
gesellschaften ja insofern fällt es mir
schwer das auf eine ganz kurze formel zu
bringen
aber der zusammenhang war ja jetzt der
zu sagen wenn es in bestimmten
europäischen gesellschaften auf den
ersten blick plausibel klingt auch da
nur auf den ersten blick dass
modernisierung zur säkularisierung führt
dann ist dies auch auf den ersten blick
für die usa nicht plausibel
auf den zweiten blick ist es auch in
europa nicht plausibel wenn man sich
eine landkarte europas vorstellen
religions- geografische landkarte
erstellt und etwa eben identifiziert wo
sind die am stärksten säkularisierten
ländern
dann sind das nicht etwa
selbstverständlich auch die am stärksten
modernisierten länder ich habe vorhin
ostdeutschland genannt niemand wird
sagen die tatsache dass ostdeutschland
wesentlich säkular ist als
westdeutschland liegt daran dass
ostdeutschland so viel moderner ist in
wirtschaftlicher hinsicht ja auch unter
den ehemals kommunistischen
gesellschaften gibt es enorme
unterschiede und selbst zwischen ländern
die einen großen teil geschichte
miteinander teilen tschechien ist eines
der säkularisierten ländern europas und
die slowakei nicht da nicht deshalb muss
man behaupte ich in dem buch nach einer
völlig anderen erklärung der
säkularisierung prozesse suchen und sich
von dieser bequemen erklärt
es liegt irgendwie an der modernisierung
und mit fortschreiten der modernisierung
heißt das dann fällt religion vermutlich
vermutlich überall weg muss man sich
befreien
aber dann haben wir doch mal ins
deutschsprachige europa sei in der
schweiz sind ein fünftel der bevölkerung
konfessionslos in deutschland über 30
prozent in österreich ein achtel der
bevölkerung
woran liegt es denn da bei deutschland
beginnt ist ja nun zunächst einmal kein
zweifel dass bei diesen zahlen sich die
enorm starke säkularisierung
ostdeutschlands natürlich niederschlägt
in ostdeutschland ist in den 50er jahren
und enormen politischen druck eine
antikirchliche und antireligiöse
kampagnen in kommunistischen regime
gefahren worden
die erfolgreich war das füge ich deshalb
hinzu weil die bloße tatsache dieses
politischen drucks alleine auch noch
nicht die erklärung sein kann nicht in
allen kommunistischen ländern war der
druck gleich erfolgreich
im benachbarten polen neben nicht oder
sehr viel weniger
und weil man sich ja auch vorstellen
kann dass nach dem ende des kommunismus
wenn der entsprechende druck weg fällt
es eine wii-version dieses
säkularisierung trend eine umkehrung
dieses säkularisierung trends gibt die
hat es aber in ostdeutschland im
wesentlichen nicht gegeben es gibt ganz
kleine anzeichen heute über die man
separat sprechen könnte ich setze bei
der erklärung von säkularisierung
prozessen ganz stark auf politische
konstellationen das soll heißen auf die
stellungnahme der kirchen und
religionsgemeinschaften zu zentralen
politischen fragen ich zähle in dem buch
auf die nationale frage die soziale
frage wie man im 19 jahrhundert gesagt
hat bezogen auf die lage der arbeiter
die demokratische frage wie die fragen
der menschenrechte der individual-
richtete der gleichstellung der frau und
so weiter aber ich stelle mich richtig
also wenn kirchen kirchen gemeinschaften
sich zu politischen fragen äußern dann
hat das einen einfluss auf säkularismus
und das behaupte ich tatsächlich ich bin
ich behaupte etwa dass es im 19
jahrhundert in deutschland auch in
einigen anderen europäischen ländern
aber eben nicht überall eine
enttäuschung geschichte der arbeit der
arbeiterschaft gegenüber vor allem in
deutschland der evangelischen kirche
gegeben hat ja man hat das gefühl
entwickelt als arbeiter das könnte ich
jetzt auf allen ebenen schildern dass in
politischer hinsicht die kirche so
fusioniert ist mit dem staat und somit
dem existierenden zum beispiel in
greußen regime gewissermaßen ja dass die
arbeiter überhaupt kein gehör finden mit
ihren interessen auf seiten der kirche
das geht bis in das detail hinein ich
habe gelesen dass bei einer von
evangelischen pastoren amateurhaften
durchgeführten also quasi soziologischen
untersuchungen warum kommen leute in
berlin nichts in den gottesdienst im
neunzehnten jahrhundert ein pastor also
antwortet dass ihm die leute sagen sie
kamen am sonntag nicht in den
gottesdienst weil sie nichts richtiges
anzuziehen hätten nichts richtiges für
den gottesdienst anzuziehen hätten das
heißt sie haben das gefühl gehabt einen
bestimmten bürgerlichen kleidungs kommt
am sonntag nicht entsprechen zu können
was mich daran so erschüttert hat war
dass der pastor
das gewissermaßen nur registriert und
nicht denkt dass er vielleicht einen
etwas ändern müsste also klare machen
müsste dass man nicht in großartigen
sonntagsstaat sein muss wenn man am
sonntag in den gottesdienst grund wenn
also ich will eine tiefe kulturelle und
politische entfremden
zwischen kirche und in dem fall
arbeiterschaft schildern die etwa im
ruhrgebiet weitgehend katholisch viel
weniger oder nicht eingetreten ist also
wo es gelungen ist der kirche den draht
sozusagen zu den arbeitern zu behalten
und wodurch weniger arbeiter sich einer
prononciert säkularen form von arbeiter
bewegung wie es die deutsche
sozialdemokratische bewegung war
angeschlossen aber das heißt wenn die
religionsgemeinschaften es schaffen sich
auch der probleme der konkreten alltags-
probleme der leute deren themen
aufzunehmen
dann habt ihr eine chance dass sie eben
dass die leute bleiben und wenn sie sich
zu weit distanziert
auch von der lebenswelt der leute dann
führt dass er zum dazu dass ich die
leute dann abwenden von denke ich
tatsächlich bin ich der meinung ich muss
sich ein kleines bisschen noch
spezifizieren aber tatsächlich bin ich
eben der meinung dass man nicht denken
darf die einzige ebene auf der sich das
motiv in der kirche zu sein oder
auszutreten abspielt wäre ein im engsten
sinn religiöses motiv sondern das
tatsächlich in meinem sinn politischen
motive in diesem sehr weiten sind also
nicht unbedingt parteipolitisch sein
muss ja eine ganz zentrale rolle spielen
daraus folgt nicht und das meinte ich
als ich gerade gesagt habe das muss ich
noch etwas spezifizieren dass ich sage
die kirchen müssen wie gewissermaßen
wahlkämpfenden parteien sich an
demoskopischen umfragen orientieren oder
an dem was im augenblick populär ist
wenn ich dass das für mich so wichtige
thema des dritten reiches in deutschland
beziehen darf wenn 1903 und
die kirchen sich massiv in deutschland
gegen den nationalsozialismus gestellt
hätten hätten sie einerseits macht wenig
vieles zu befürchten gehabt vielleicht
aber auch um popularität geerntet weil
das ja eben nicht unpopulär war was da
passiert ist zumindest sagt zu beginn
und da würde ich natürlich sagen für
eine kirchenleitung dürfte jetzt nicht
ausschlaggebend sein der gesichtspunkt
wie behalten wir möglichst viele sondern
was ist in sich von christlichen ethos
her gerechtfertigt und wenn man das tut
muss man dann auch unpopularität in kauf
nehmen ja also möchte ich schon
verstanden bisher nur für
säkularisierung ausschlaggebend ist
nicht wirtschaftswachstum und sind nicht
wissenschafts fortschritte sondern ist
eine ganze sphäre in der verarbeitet
wird was wirtschaftlich oder
wissenschaftlich passiert ist und in der
kirchen und religionsgemeinschaften wird
sein scheitern können sie können als
bloß abwehr und gegenüber dem was da
neues geschieht wahrgenommen werden als
den kontakt verlieren und gleichzeitig
so auftreten als hätten sie die weisheit
mit dem löffel gefressen
aber es ist ja schon dann die frage für
die kirchen wie reagieren sie auf den
mitgliederverlust auf die
fortschreitende säkularisierung und sie
haben es angesprochen
da muss ein mittelweg gefunden werden
zwischen eben sich nicht einfach jeden
tag geist anpassen
aber auch die andere tendenz dass man
einfach so aufs entscheidungs
christentum port und sagt egal wenn wir
nur noch ganz wenige sind habt doch die
haben die richtige lehre also dass man
da so was ja das ist ja das ist ja
traditionell das was er für sekten in
wertfreie sind gesagt für kleine
religiöse gruppen charakteristisch ist
als für die großen kirchen die größe der
katholische gibt das war noch kein
benzen das bedaure ich sehr ich halte da
ja das ist völlig richtig ich sage aber
dazu oft dass das eigentlich sehr und
katholisch ist
also dass die katholische kirche
eigentlich eher in der tradition hat
einen sozusagen sehr weiten mantel für
viele viele gläubige ganz verschiedene
orientierung und so weiter auszuwerfen
diese vorstellung überhaupt dass die
katholische kirche so ein gewissermaßen
ein wenig ironisch zentralistisches
gebilde ist stammt ja in dieser form
erst aus dem neunzehnten jahrhundert ja
und erst in den letzten jahrzehnten gab
es jetzt tatsächlich kräfte die das so
zu spielen sind
das ist für mich wie sekten haft klingt
ja also wir legen gar keinen wert darauf
dass diejenigen bei uns bleiben die
nicht jedem punkt der lehre zum beispiel
auf dem gebiet der sexualmoral zustimmen
da aber fast niemand dazu stimmt ja wenn
man das ernst nehmen würde eine
ungeheure schrumpfen
da gibt es diese umfrage die parks
franziskus in auftrag gegeben hat über
die familien trust er als wären sie dann
gesprochen
da tun sich natürlich wahnsinn getrieben
aber zwischen dem was die offizielle
lehre ist beispiel sexualmoral und dem
was die die basis denkt und lebt
erwarten sie da jetzt große änderung
sieht man die ergebnisse sind in
deutschland österreich unterwegs schon
publiziert
es erstaunt ja niemanden dass das
geschraubte man hier hat die frage ist
aber jetzt passiert ja jetzt was also
ich würde das zunächst einmal so
beschreiben dass das ein irgendwie
genialer schachzug des papstes
franziskus ist er ist ja doch in dem
problem dass er nicht einerseits etwa
für eine stärkere dezentralisierung für
eine realisierung der katholischen
kirche eintreten kann und andererseits
das wirklich im autoritären sinn
verhängen darf
das ist ein problem von dem ich manchmal
etwas ironisch sage in dem sich auch
michael gorbatschow gefunden hat naja
also ein sozusagen hochgradig
hierarchisches gebildet wo alles auf den
oben
blickt der will nun das ruder
herumwerfen wenn er aber das ruder
autoritär herum wirft läuft er gefahr
den zusammenhalt des ganzen zu gefährden
dann hat er zwar versucht etwas zu
ändern
aber er hat eigentlich kritisiert oder
spaltung herbeigeführt und was
franziskus nun gemacht hat finde ich ist
eben viel klüger er hat nicht dekretiert
von heute auf morgen ändere die
katholische kirche bestimmte lehrern
sondern er hat im besten sinn der
aufklärerischen rolle von umfragen und
so weiter gesagt schauen wir uns doch
einfach mal an wie die menschen wirklich
mit diesen kirchlichen lehren verfahren
und wie sie sagen für niemanden
überraschend also niemand der selber in
der kirche ist oder viele menschen in
der katholischen kirche kennt ist
überrascht davon dass sie sich an viele
wir lehren im engen sinn ich halte
glaube nicht dass das die fundamentalen
lehrern des christentums betrifft aber
in ihrer eigenen praxis die meisten auch
gläubig stan kirchenmitgliedern nicht
halten und dass sie diese lehren einfach
auch ignorieren
ja also das heißt schon gar nicht mehr
für einen entspannenden gegenstand der
widerlegung halt sondern sie einfach
beiseite lassen ja das kommt jetzt
unwiderleglich damit heraus das ist so
ein bisschen wie bei johannes dem 23 das
berühmte fenster öffnen und anlassen von
frischer luft finde ich über die
konsequenz
wird es ein massives ringen der
verschiedenen kräfte geben
ich habe aber schon das wort
dezentralisierung einfließen lassen weil
ich wirklich glaube einer der wege um
die katholische kirche vor
spaltungstendenzen zu bewahren ist
tatsächlich dass manche entscheidungen
nicht auf globaler ebene festgelegt sind
sondern stärker in verschiedenen
weltregionen verschiedenen praktiziert
werden können
nochmal auf die die säkularisierung
jetzt in europa zu sprechen zu kommen es
gibt ja dann immer wieder auch so die
ängstliche frage hat das christentum in
europa überhaupt zukunft oder ist das
dem untergang geweiht
das prognostizieren laut prognosen sind
für wissenschaftler ein bisschen spiele
ja also ich habe einmal eine einladung
zu einem vertrag gehabt genau dieser art
und hat man mir den titel vorgeschlagen
wandert das christentum aus europa aus
und zur illustration in den respekt der
vortrags ankündigung war ein bild mit
vollkommen leeren kirchenbänke dann habe
ich zuerst gesagt das bild will ich
bitte nicht weil es auch nicht zutrifft
ab auch wenn der anteil der menschen die
am sonntag in den gottesdienst gehen
massiv gesunken ist auch auf der
katholischen seite und auf der
protestantischen war immer schon
niedriger ist in absoluten zahlen
die zahl der sonntäglichen kirchenbesuch
eine beträchtliche zahl also in
deutschland einige millionen menschen zu
welcher veranstaltung jeden sonntag geht
schon einige millionen menschen hin
aber ganz wichtig ist jetzt dass eine
der großen veränderungen in europa in
den letzten jahrzehnten
die migration nicht nur von muslimen
sondern auch von christ nach europa ist
das ist in verschiedenen ländern sehr
unterschiedlich
deutschland hat sehr stark eine
muslimische immigration aber frankreich
und großbritannien zum beispiel haben
viele einwanderer aus afrika und aus der
karibik die oft christen sind und die
ein außerordentlich vitalis christentum
nach europa bringen
in einem buch von dem britisch
amerikanischen historiker philip jenkins
stand das in london heute die mehrzahl
der sonntäglichen kirchenbesuch an einem
beliebigen sonntag schwarze hautfarbe
weil die weiße mängel in der so wenig
gehen und weil die schwarzen migranten
so viel gehen jetzt habe ich bei
irgendeinem vortrag zitiert und dann
sagte jemand in frankfurt am main sei es
genauso also da habe ich jetzt kennen
sicheren beleg dafür aber auch wenn es
nicht ganz genau stimmt ist doch die
bemerkungen anzeichen dafür dass es eine
vitalisierende wirkung der christlichen
migration nach europa auf das
europäische christentum geben kann
auspressen zum wandern nicht aus sondern
ein
so habe ich das buch beendet mit diesem
ein bisschen witz natürlich es ist
deshalb ein bisschen ein witz weil eben
in europa das christentum selbst ohne
einwanderung auch nicht so mobil bunt
ist wie es oft übertreiben kann
geschildert wird zumindest nicht eben in
allen ländern und selbst in ländern wie
schweden in denen sehr wenige menschen
am sonntag in den gottesdienst gehen
heißt das noch nicht wirklich das nicht
zum beispiel zu wichtigen lebens
ereignissen oder zur deutung wichtige
lebens ereignisse oder in moralischen
urteilen
über vieles die christlichen traditionen
wie vital sie dann im einzelnen sind ja
ist die frage aber eine große rolle für
das verhalten der menschen spielen
was werden wir den verlieren wenn das
christentum aussterben wird also ich bin
ein geschworener gegner der
argumentation mit nutzen und funktionen
was religion betrifft also ich möchte
nicht sagen dass christen tun darf
deshalb sozusagen nicht schwächer werden
oder aussterben weil dann die leute
weniger gesund wären oder der soziale
zusammenhalt gefördert werden
unglücklich das kann zwar alles sein und
über all diese einzelnen fragen gibt es
auch empirische religions-
psychologische religion soziologische
untersuchungen
das ist auch alles von interesse ich
weigere mich deshalb aber so zu reden
weil der glaube nicht präsentiert werden
darf wie in den autos aggressions
therapie
ja also im sinn von sie ein das ist eine
gesundheit nützt und dann macht ihr
etwas zu zeigen was die irgendwie im
kopf nicht einleuchtet deshalb arbeite
ich stärker daran zu zeigen dass der
christliche glaube etwas ist was man
sozusagen auch als wahrheit akzeptieren
kann nicht weil es irgendwie nützlich
oder einen effekt hat der einzige punkt
wo ich selber eine sorge äußere in dem
buch die sorge hinsichtlich der
möglichen wirkungen einer
fortschreitenden säkularisierung ist der
das ich sagen das christentum ist sicher
eine der stärksten formen nicht die
einzige einige stärksten formen in denen
auf der welt das ethos denkt an alle
anderen menschen nicht nur an dich oder
an die mitglieder der familie oder
deines volkes oder auch nur deiner
religionsgemeinde
in denen dieses ethos also man sagt in
der philosophie der moralischen
universalismus ja das wohl aller
menschen ist der höchste moralische
bezugspunkt also das christentum ist
eine der stärksten formen in denen das
artikuliert worden ist da wegfallen oder
die schwächung des christentums würde
eine schwächung einer der großen säulen
des moralischen universalismus sein wenn
man in die stars in meinen augen und wo
die sehen das nicht so
die denken dass an die stelle des
wegfallenden christentums ein säkularer
moralischer universalismus treten würde
aufklärerischer art beispielsweise und
den gibt es zwar aber unter den
säkularen orientierungen muss das nicht
die bestimmende sein
das wundert mich immer dass manche
säkularisten so argumentieren als wäre
klar dass säkularismus heißt eine
säkulare form des moralischen
universalismus dabei ist die geschichte
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts reich an
säkularisten die neue
partikularinteressen
sozialismus hat das wohl des deutschen
volkes in einem bestimmten verständnis
oder der arischen rasse als obersten
bezugspunkt gehabt und der stalin ismus
und auch der poststellen es muss also
ich habe mir mit einer den eigenen uhr
an einen ddr philosophen sagen hören in
den 70er jahren
der oberste moralische bezugspunkt ist
nützt dies der deutschen demokratischen
republik oder nützt es der sache des
sozialismus und damit ist der
moralischen universalismus zerstört
durch säkularismus also die schwächen
des christentums kann in moralischer
hinsicht eine schwächung des monats
universalismus darstellen damit haben
sie jetzt auch gerade gut übergeleitet
eben zur zweiten these die ich mit ihnen
diskutieren möchte die frage für zwei
cool arisierung zu moral verluste sind
jetzt grad schon angekommen
was ich nicht verstehe was jetzt gesagt
haben
warum ist dieser universalismus dem
christentum vorbehalten also warum strom
halten aber sie sagen schon zum teil
sehr dezidierte sprechen von der
überlegenheit des christlichen liebe es
etwas gegenüber allen formen
universalistische moralphilosophie aber
zum beispiel ist die buddhistische ewig
doch nicht hätten anderen also moment
ich habe ausdrücklich vorhin gerade
gesagt dass der christliche moralische
universalismus nur einer von mehreren
ist also nicht der einzige dies liebe es
etwas ist ja nochmal was anderes als der
moralische universalismus ja also um es
noch klarer zu sagen ich bin der meinung
und das gehört zu einem seiner der
stärksten gegenstände weil der
gegenwärtigen arbeit dass alle einer
bestimmten historischen zeitpunkt den
karl jaspers die achsen zeit genannt hat
mitte des letzten vorchristlichen
jahrtausends in verschiedenen kulturen
der welt in indien in china bei den
juden und bei den antiken griechen die
vorstellung von menschheit auf gekommen
ist und in diesem sinn die vorstellung
eines moralischen universalismus ja und
alle diese ursprünge haben ihre
wirkungsmacht bis heute behalten
buddhismus konfuzianismus in bestimmten
formen indische religion und im
weiterwirken der klassischen
griechischen philosophie und des
judentums und das christentum und der
islam gehören dann sozusagen zu nicht in
dieser zeit entstanden sondern erst
später entstanden in formen in denen der
jüdische und den antik griechische
aufbruch
bzw zehn thesen eingegangen sind also
insofern und es gibt zeit im 18ten
jahrhundert spätestens vielleicht schon
länger wenn man die steuer dazu rechnen
würde in der antike verschiedene formen
eines nichtreligiösen moralischen
universalismus also ich gehöre gerade zu
denen die sagen was heute angesagt ist
ist nicht das pathos der christen zu
sagen wir sind die einzigen moralischen
universalisten sonst gibt es nun kein
christentum kein moralischer
universalismus sondern im interesse des
moralischen universalismus brauchen wir
eine koalition dieser verschiedenen
religiösen und verschiedenen säkularen
formen des moralischen universalismus
aber sami bis etwas aber geht darüber
hinaus aber sagen sie trotzdem dass
religion egal ob jetzt kräftig bläst
oder irgendwie dass das diesen
moralischen universalismus also dass man
eben nicht nur auf sich schaut nicht nur
auf seine eigene sondern eben auf jeden
menschen dass religion das bestärkt dass
ich meine das werden wahrscheinlich auch
alle freidenkern sich gehabt er sage ich
doch also ich habe gesagt man muss
unterscheiden zwischen der frage wie kam
etwas historisch zum ersten mal in die
welt und da behaupte ich kann eine
gewisse form in die welt in dieser
achsen zeit und selbst in der
griechischen philosophie bei platon
werde ist falsch die diese philosophie
als anti religiös aufzufassen
es ist eine höhe entwicklung der
griechischen religion über die gelebte
griechische religion hinaus auf dieser
grundlage aber eines also einmal
entstandenen moral
universalismus gibt es nun
unbezweifelbar säkulare denke oder
kräfte oder bewegungen die sagen diesen
moralischen universalismus machen wir
uns ganz zu eigen
aber wir behaupten dass diese religiösen
kräfte die in herbeigeführt haben ihnen
gar nicht konsequent verfolgt haben oder
in um sein bestes jeweils wieder
gebracht haben indem sie zum beispiel er
das wohl dieser eigenen
religionsgemeinschaft in den vordergrund
gerückt haben und so sind zum beispiel
im 18 späten 18ten vor allem dann im
neunzehnten jahrhundert wichtige figuren
des europäischen geisteslebens
identifizierbar
die einen leidenschaftlichen moralischen
universalismus verfechten gegen religion
und main bündnis aufruf gerade soll die
ja gerade ansprechen aber eben auch
sagen lasst uns keine unnötige
auseinandersetzungen führen für die
zentralen politischen und moralischen
streitfragen der gegenwart ist das
wichtigste das bündnis der
universalisten gegen religiöse und
nichtreligiöse formen von
partikularismus nationalismen
beispielsweise rassismen und so weiter
ja also sehe ich dieses ich glaube nur
jetzt in christentum und im buddhismus
aber nicht in allen formen des
moralischen universalismus sondern in
diesen religiösen traditionen steckt
noch etwas drinnen was ich als liebes
etwas bezeichnet was über den bloßen
gesichtspunkt universeller gerechtigkeit
noch hinausgeht was den gerechtigkeit
gesichtspunkt zb durch gnaden
gesichtspunkte noch mal relativiert ein
bisschen erklären warum stellen sie
unter dem christlichen liebe ja gut
zunächst einmal für jeden der irgendwas
vom christentum verheißt nahe liegen die
aufforderung liebe deinen nächsten wie
dich selbst und der zusammenhang der
gottesliebe mit dieser radikal
verstandenen nächstenliebe radikal
verstanden
im sinn von jesu aufforderung sogar
seine feinde zu lieben
nun glaube ich nicht dass das liebes
ethos in diesem sinne von jesus gemeint
war als etwas was an die stelle von
gerechtigkeitsvorstellungen treten soll
ja sondern ist solchen zutritt zu den
gerechtigkeitsvorstellungen also es geht
darum ein gemeinwesen gerecht
einzurichten das sind viele fragen was
das genau heißt aber also das lasse ich
jetzt für den augenblick dahingestellt
dann aber kommt noch hinzu die frage
meinetwegen jemand hat ein verbrechen
begangen
jemand hat unter gerechtigkeit
gesichtspunkte nicht anspruch auf eine
bestimmte leistung und das dann das ende
ist oder ob es noch etwas zusätzlichen
bedarf was uns zum beispiel
sensibilisiert erst einmal für das leid
anderer so dass ein gesichtspunkt der in
den öffentlichen debatten über
gerechtigkeit bisher gar keine rolle
gespielt hat und der von den betroffenen
vielleicht gar nicht artikuliert werden
kann weil sie gar keine chance haben
zugang zur öffentlichkeit zu finden
aufgenommen wird als ein x-beliebiges
beispiel dass mir gerade einfällt ist
kommt heraus auf den baustellen für die
[Musik]
fußball-weltmeisterschaft stadion in
katar sterben nepalesische arbeit durch
die unerträglichen arbeitsbedingungen
diese nepalesischen arbeiter haben
überhaupt keine chance ihr leid in die
internationale öffentliche diskussion
hinein zu bringen
es bedarf der menschen die sich nicht
zufrieden geben
mit dem was schon teil der gerechtigkeit
es debatten ist sondern es bedarf auch
noch der menschen die überhaupt
wahrnehmungs offen sind für ein noch
nicht zum thema gemacht es leid und ich
behaupte dass in dem liebes ethos ein
solches sensibilisieren dass moment
drinnen stehen ja also aufmerksam zu
werden
auf etwas was mich gar nicht betrifft
eigentlich das finde ich jetzt
interessant weil es gab vor ein paar
jahren eine studie der national fall
durchgeführt hat da wurde untersucht
oder das ergebnis war dass religiöse
menschen mehr mitgefühl zeigen gegenüber
bettlern oder obdachlosen aber das nicht
religiöse toleranter sind gegenüber
ausländern frauen homosexuellen juden
muslimen also das finde ich dann schon
da da fragt man sich ja irgendwie drängt
das dann offenbar was jetzt gerade
erklärt haben oft in der praxis dann
nicht wirklich durch einen aber so kann
man solche ergebnisse nicht
interpretieren und zwar das heißt nicht
ich erzähle ich weiß auch gerade bezogen
auf die schweiz kenne ich ergebnisse die
ebenso lauten dass man in christliche
milieus in der schweiz eben gegenüber
muslimischen migranten eher vorurteils
voll sind als säkularisierte und selbst
wenn die wagen auch klar wobei das ist
jetzt nicht so überraschend
wenn bestimmte kirchliche lehre und so
ausfallen ja aber wenn man als liebens
etwas denkt daran will auch klar nein
völlig klar
aber wenn wir wir dürfen doch nicht
denken dass die enorm anspruchsvolle
ethik des christentums sich eins zu eins
niederschlägt in den persönlichen ethos
derer die sich zum christentum bekennen
ich sag dir gerade man darf solche
ergebnisse sind deshalb nicht so
internet also für die nicht so
interpretieren weil die beiden begriffe
religiös wärst du es nicht religiös auf
beiden seiten das zusammen wäre
was ich die ganze zeit gerade
unterscheiden wollte nämlich ehrlich
universalistische orientierte menschen
mit partikularismus orientierten
menschen ich habe ja gesagt unter den
religiösen gibt es welche für die im
christentum eine art vereinsabzeichen ja
sie gehören zu den christen und sie
haben deshalb gegen alle nicht christian
etwas zum beispiel ja oder sie vertreten
innerhalb des christentums auffassungen
die dazu führen dass die spezielle
lebenslage zum beispiel von
homosexuellen nur modernisiert und nicht
ernsthaft zur kenntnis genommen wird
aber so ist es auf der seite der
nichtreligiösen grundsätzlich auch da
gibt es eben auch wirkliche
universalisten und sozusagen bornierte
partikularen und wenn man nach religiös
versus nicht religiös sortiert
unterscheidet man nicht universal ist
schon fertig oder die mindestens vier
felder aufmachen wollen so zieren stehe
ich aber trotzdem glaube ich es doch
legitim dass man an leute die sich
explizit als christen bezeichnen viele
gewissen anspruch aber ich kann jetzt
geht's richtung beispiel sagen also die
frage für säkularisierung zu moral
verlust man kann ja fragen führt
religion zu moral verlusten und sich zb
die kriminalgeschichte des christentums
von karlheinz deschner vornehmen und
dann hat man sehr viele belege wo man
sagen kann na ja also das mit
christentum und moral das ist seine
sache
ich verstehe schon jetzt möchte ich
zunächst einmal in erinnerung rufen weil
das jetzt allmählich einen falschen
clown annimmt dass ich nicht etwa die
these verfechte säkularisierung führt zu
moral verfall sondern dass der punkt
meines buches ist zu sagen dass diese
nicht
während die säkularisten immer behauptet
haben modernisierung führt automatisch
zur säkularisierung sage ich hätten die
gläubigen meistens behauptet und der
säkularisierung gewarnt säkularisierung
führe zu moral verfall und ich sage ja
nun genau kann man eigentlich nicht
feststellen
deshalb möchte ich jetzt nicht aus der
ecke heraus argumentieren als hätte ich
genau das gegenteil behaupten also und
das stelle auch hundertprozentig zu wenn
jemand für sich in anspruch nimmt ein so
außerordentlich großartiges etwas zu
vertreten wie das eines des christlichen
liebe sethos natürlich darf und muss er
dann gefragt werden ob seine
auffassungen im einzelnen seiner
handlungen im einzelnen dem entsprechen
man sollte das nicht höhe nicht tun also
man sollte schon das begleit bewusstsein
immer haben dass wir alle schwach sind
also auch die säkularen universalisten
mit verlaub die ich kenne in großer zahl
im akademischen leben sind in ihrem
persönlichen moralischen verhalten oft
nicht besonders imponierend und ich gehe
auch nicht zu jedem sagen wir säkularen
kann diana hin wenn er an irgendeiner
intrige mitgewirkt hat und sagt wie
vereinbart du das mit einem kanton ismus
und insofern meinigmann so sollte man
nicht mit den gewissermaßen pharisäer
haften moralischen selbstgefühl des
säkularen an die gläubigen herr anderen
sagen ihr seid auch keine besseren
menschen ja sondern das muss ein auf
beiden seiten menschen sich demütig
geführter dialog sein auf dem man sich
vor allem dann ein glas und doch das was
wir gemeinsam wir das gute halten
gemeint haben auch vertreten und in die
tat umsetzen
ich möchte gerne noch einen schritt
weiter gehen
es geht ab so ein bisschen in die
richtung von wegen der säkularisierung
und moral
sie haben in ihrem buch ein
interessantes kapitel es geht um
religion und gewalt und da beschreiben
sie es gibt strukturelle ähnlichkeit
zwischen der erfahrung von religionen
zwischen erfahrung von selbst
transzendenz sehen
dass die erfahrung des heiligen und der
erfahrung von gewalt
das ist etwas was man nicht gerade
zusammenbringen würde es genau wie geht
das zusammen
ich weiß dass das ein unheimlicher
gedanken ist und ich möchte auch um
gottes willen nicht so verstanden werden
als würde ich sagen dass sein dass
gleich es gibt nur unheimliche
strukturelle gemeinsamkeiten als in
einem ersten schritt kann man sich das
vergegenwärtigen
wenn man sich klarmacht dass gewalt tun
für viele vielleicht nicht für viele
aber für manche menschen ein lustvolles
und sie überwältigendes erlebnis ist das
ist das unheimliche daran beim in
zivilisierten bedingungen denken wir
leben wir so dass wir uns einig sind
gewalt ist etwas böses nun wissen wir
aber zum beispiel ich habe ja zwei
bücher über krieg auch geschrieben und
mit viel mit der
sozialwissenschaftlichen erforschung von
kriegen und der langzeit wirkungen der
teilhabe an kriegen also soldaten nach
dem ende des krieges beschäftigt dass
soldaten dienen zum beispiel also
darüber habe ich besonders gearbeitet
wird ein krieg die us soldaten im
vietnamkrieg waren dort konfrontiert
etwa mit guerillas als gegner nicht mit
einer anderen armee sich haben hinreißen
lassen zivilbevölkerung zu massakrieren
frauen kinder und bewaffnete männer weil
sie nicht wussten ob das vielleicht ein
plötzlich auftauchender guerilla kämpfer
ist und jetzt kommt das aller
unheimlichste und das nachträglich das
abknallen von
entschuldigen als ekstatische erfahrung
auch sich bewusst machen und in der
situation haben diese menschen zwei
verschiedene möglichkeiten würde ich
sagen oder ein spektrum von
möglichkeiten zwischen zwei extremen das
eine ist zu sagen um gottes willen
wie konnte mich der krieg nur so
verändern dass ich sachen getan habe die
ich moralisch völlig verdamme und die
ich niemals getan hätte wenn ich nicht
in diesen krieg kommen wäre bis hin zum
anderen ende und das gibt es auch
menschen die sagen sie haben
gewissermaßen ihr wahres ich unter
diesen umständen entdeckt also ist
unvergesslich die äußerung von einem in
einer so genannten web group heißt das
also ausspreche gruppe von veteranen der
sagt in vietnam ist mir klar geworden
dass ich ein monster bin er nicht gesagt
vietnam hat mich zu einem monster
gemacht so gesagt dass ich ein monster
bin
und jemand der sich selber in diesem
sinne als gewalt lustempfinden das
monster empfindet er wird mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit gewalttaten verüben
auch jetzt in seinem zivilleben und
statistisch ist es auch keine frage dass
das also das ist nachweislich so ja also
eine hohe neigung zur gewaltkriminalität
bei leuten bei denen eine solche
entdeckung stattgefunden hat also der
erste schritt der argumentation ist zu
sagen wenn religiöse erfahrung
wesentlich in einer in einem
begeisterten überschreiten der grenzen
besteht und bei der gewalt lust
erfahrung auch ein solches überschreiten
der grenzen stattfindet gibt es hier
eine unheimliche gemeinsamkeit es gibt
natürlich aber enorme differenzen die
aber trotzdem auf eine art gemeinsamkeit
auch hinweisen
wer begeistert ist
etwa von einer religiösen erfahrung
möchte diese teilen sogar bei einer
nichtreligiösen selbst transzendenz
erfahren wie dem verlieben ist es
bekanntlich so dass menschen die sich
frisch verliebt haben sich kaum
beherrschen können anderen zu erzählen
dass sie sich frisch verliebt haben
sozusagen also ich schnitze es gern in
jede rinnende ein heißt es in einem lied
und so weiter also man möchte mit allen
mitteln kommunizieren
bei der gewalt erfahrung ist typisch
dass man über sie eigentlich nicht
sprechen kann
also genau das gegenteil könnte man
sagen aber darin liegt auch die
gemeinsamkeit die verarbeitung im einen
fall ist sprich entsprechend sprechen
und im anderen fall verstummen und
überwindung gewissermaßen der erfahren
und der traumatisierung der erfahrung
als täter oder opfer
wenn die fähigkeit nach langem
vielleicht erst erworben ist über diese
erfahrungen zu sprechen also so gehe ich
in einer weise die jetzt die leicht
missverstanden werden kann den
strukturellen ähnlichkeiten zwischen was
ich sage die positiven erfahrungen der
selbst renz tendenz und gewalt erfahren
es ist ja interessant weil wenn ich
richtig informiert bin sind ja ihre
beiden forschungs oder habt
forschungsgebiete in religion und werte
und auf der andern seite kriegen gewalt
trotzdem bringen sie das selten
irgendwie in verbindung richtig ich habe
mich sogar also es lustig ist dass ich
vor allem nach nine eleven also dem 2001
großen terroristischen anschlägen also
mich kaum retten konnte vor einladungen
zu vorträgen über religion und gewalt
weil das gewissermaßen das war jetzt das
thema und ich eben einer von denen von
dem was ankommt wer hat wie es
eigentlich haben und wie das andere also
ideal der sonne über den zusammenhang
reden und ich habe das routinemäßig
abgelehnt weil ich gesagt habe das
suggeriert einen falschen zusammenhang
also den zusammenhang derart als wir
irgendwie an den religionen etwas dran
was die religiösen menschen speziell zur
gewalttätigkeit prädisponiert und das
trifft nicht zu
und ich muss sagen ich finde es galt so
abstrus nach dem zwanzigsten jahrhundert
also dass auch nur zu denken
die größten verbrechen des zwanzigsten
jahrhundert also makro verbrechen des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts sind vom
stalinismus maoismus bis hin zu pol pot
und vom nationalsozialismus verübt
worden
und das sind beides keine religionen ja
also was mich interessiert ist natürlich
inwiefern eben säkulare formen sozialer
bewegungen ebenfalls wie etwa die
faschistischen bewegungen attraktion
auch gewinnen weil sie jungen männern im
regelfall die beteiligung an lustvollen
gewalttaten auch ermöglicht haben also
in der frühphase des italienischen
faschismus ist das ganz offensichtlich
also dass das eine rolle eine
mobilisierende rolle gespielt hat und
benito mussolini ist einer der ersten
gewesen würde ich sagen der gewalt in
diesem sinne stellt sozusagen
gerechtfertigt hat das kommt gar nicht
darauf an ob da ein wichtiger gegner
besiegt wird niedergemacht wird durch
die gewalt sondern wir machen das weil
es uns zusammenhält und uns eine
begeisternde erfahrung
also so wie ich schon bereit über
religiös motivierte gewalt und über das
alles zu sprechen aber ich werde diese
simplen zusammenhang irgendwie es neigen
die religionen zu gewalt und wir sagen
dass er das ist auch eine eigene die zur
zeit durch die beteiligung
buddhistischer mönche antiislamischen
gewalttaten in möhren oder so etwas
etwas an plausibilität verloren hat
genannt da können wir jetzt noch ganz
lange darüber reden haben wir leider die
zeit nicht mehr
ich möchte ihnen eine persönliche frage
zum schluss stellen und zwar dieses buch
widmen sie ja ihre großmutter
unterschreiben sie ihre großmutter für
die ungläubige noch exoten und der
glaube keine option sondern
selbstverständlicher kern der
lebensführung war wäre ich da auch ein
bisschen nostalgie heraus sehnsucht nach
vor der glaube noch ein leben wo der
glaube noch selbstverständlich war die
kirche noch im dorf also nostalgie nicht
in dem sinn dass ich mich zurück szene
in etwas was ich selber erlebt hätte ich
habe das nicht so erlebt und ganz zu
beginn unseres gesprächs habe ich gesagt
was ich erlebt habe war ein durch das
dritte reich hindurch gegangenes
katholisches milieu aber mit
hindurchgegangen wenn ich eben auch ein
sich ihm in vieler hinsicht an ähnelndes
und mit ihm ein verstandenes
katholisches milieu
insofern habe bin ich völlig frei von
nostalgie gegenüber einem katholischen
milieu dörflicher kleinstädtische
solcher art ich bin nicht frei von astra
gegenüber meiner großmutter könnte ich
sagen ja und gegenüber der der das ganze
leben strukturierenden kraft die der
glaube für sie hatte ja also aber das
ist was anderes nicht mehr da bin ich
eher skeptisch
und auch distanziert und ich verkörpere
das auch nicht und ich muss sogar sagen
ich glaube wenn ich da noch mehr zeit
verbracht hätte als ich verbracht haben
ich bin daher herausgegangen
dann weiß ich gar nicht welche wirkungen
das in der religiöse hinsicht alles
gehabt hätte aber dass der glaube etwas
sein kann was wirklich nicht eben im
kopf nur sitzt als irgendeine
überzeugung ja sondern was lebens
strukturiert ist und einem eben auch in
schweren lebenskrisen kraft und hoffnung
gibt und einen sensibilisiert für das
leid anderer und eigene liebes kräfte
freisetzt und so etwas vielleicht
beruhigt ihre ich das auf meine
großmutter ja aber das verbinde ich mit
ihr und das war ein grund warum ich das
buch gewidmet habe ich bedanke mich sehr
herzlich dass sie mein gast
danke ihnen für das gespräch
[Musik]
eines dieser gespräche dass man sich
gerne noch einmal ansieht
sie können das tun online sie finden es
auf unserer kultur plattform
dort finden sie auch ein interview mit
dem philosophen volker gerhardt denn die
gretchenfrage wie hast du's mit der
religion hat konjunktur
bei philosophen nächste woche übertragen
wir einen ganz besonderen gottesdienst
und zwar allen serbisch-orthodoxen wir
zeigen eindrücke einer mehrstündigen
göttlichen liturgie aus der einzigen
ganz ausgemalten orthodoxen kirche der
schweiz
diese steht in belp er sei zitat der
deutschen literatur skurrilster humorist
gesagt hat dass kein geringerer als
marcel reich ranicki und vermutlich
hatte recht
hermann burger der mann aus worten
sprach artist zauberkünstler vor 25
jahren hat er sich das leben genommen
was ist vom autor von shilton geblieben
dazu ein gespräch mega metropolen enge
wohnräume und verdichtetes bauen
der architekt min zum tor hat eine
alternative lebensraum nicht als
festgefügte muster sondern als
vertikales dorf ein film
[Musik]